do you receive emails or twitter dms or
facebook inquiries from filmmakers that
say I'm just getting started can you
give me tips by their own crowd funding
or filming I do yeah I do I a lot on
facebook a lot and once in a while
through my blog it's about not about
crowdfunding as much anymore because I I
definitely don't try to tell myself as
an expert I had I did her article a blog
post like two years ago after my first
campaign and after that didn't feel I
had too much more to say about it and so
I don't really get asked that anymore
but it's more about people saying you
know you have a career in it you made a
lot of feature films like what cameras
do you use or how do you produce a movie
can ask you advice on getting it done on
a little budget like that kind of stuff
so what are some of your standard tips
that you tell people if you can reveal
them I know yes for 995 what I read us
who was it maybe was Robert Altman or
something or they're like my advice is
like don't take any advice you know
because it's it's so case by case and I
guess there's certain best practices
where it's just smart to to do but for
the most part everything every project
is always so different like you can't
just apply one set of rules and expect
it's gonna work the only thing I always
say is definitely just don't give up you
know its persistence I've been doing the
mifi my first ruffle man I made nine
years ago my my first feature i shot in
2008 you know and I've been going at it
for almost nine or ten years now and I
just feel my big toe is getting in the
door just just getting barely in the
door you know
if I stopped and who knows if I'll ever
make it you know and of course making it
is defined differently but it's
something where someone who wants to
make a film you just can't give up
because one of the main things and then
my of my my mantra on the set is always
have a back-up plan so you want a you
want choice a but you're actually given
choices B and C you know but have those
choices ready to go because if you don't
have a back-up plan on the set
everyone's gonna be looking at you and
you just you know cut with your pants
down you don't know what you're gonna do
then you know that's not a good
situation and then you might lose
authority yada yada yada so just be
prepared that's my main things be ready
for anything well you were in the
corporate realm years ago right you work
toward a 40-hour week corporate job
thank you mentioned on our show so do
you ever receive emails from people that
say you know what I wanted to leave my
job and and you know put a second
mortgage on the house and make a film or
things like that were they asked you to
really like tough financial question and
I know you say case-by-case basis but
what do you tell people about making
that huge leap do you say a little bit
at a time
thankfully I haven't had that big
question where I had that you know
responsibility to tell them what to do
if anyone were to move completely out of
their job number one for me I'm just
lucky that I found my passion because a
lot of people say you know you're just
like you know what you want to do
because a lot of people in their 9 to 5s
are making a lot of money but they don't
really know what really makes them happy
you know so I'm thankful for that and I
think those people that aren't happy and
if they know what they really want to do
they definitely should like you said
slowly get into it like if they're
making great money or even decent money
there's there's ways to play around with
your passion whether it be you know
making a small short film with your
iPhone first you know and I always make
a joke like you can film your tan from
your pet you don't have an actor like
it's film your pet but you do something
you cut you cut together like you play
with whatever passions you paint
you do whatever and you feel if it's
going to happen or not like if that's
something once you do it based on the
response based on your intrinsic
response and personally what it made you
feel like you wanted to keep going then
you don't do it otherwise you know it's
something you may not want to want to
like quit your job to do
you